[Music]
one of the things though that really
impresses me about the show
and the writing is that it's pretty much
just a number of characters
in in like uh in a house a lot of the
time it's
you guys aren't going and leaving and
doing um well
sometimes but it keeps the momentum
never slows down
there's always something like an onion
is constantly being pulled back
can you sort of talk about that that
that every episode is pulling
like a it never slows down um
i think on paper you'd think kind of a
show that's all set in
one place would feel quite restrictive
but i think
one of the things in this season i think
you find the house kind of grows and
becomes
a whole new thing there's whole other
places of the house that you've never
seen before it's almost like a labyrinth
of rooms
and uh yeah it's a really interesting
place to work because it's
it does it though it's very kind of
contained it's very
intimate and kind of everything is kind
of amplified
and the atmosphere is kind of quite
unique
so it's yes it's an interesting place to
to play a scene for sure
yeah yeah i mean for sure i think we
were striving for not wanting
the uh because i think at the end of
season one it's such a
such a high energy kind of end to the
first ten episodes that we didn't
wanna then hit a dip in a lull i think
we want to keep the tension
as high as possible for the whole season
i mean knight always says that it's like
remember the thriller remember the
tension
um so yeah hopefully we keep you on the
edge of your seat as long as possible
um and then it reaches this big climax
at the end of
season two and i won't give anything
away though um
but yeah i think i think that's all
going on
rupert i have to ask you um half the
scenes i think you're holding
a glass of wine and the basement of this
house has the most amazing wine cellar
um do you leave set wanting wine or you
like
never give it to me again
no i know you mean i've never really
been a wine guy
it's never really been something i kind
of go for
but um yeah definitely being part of
this show has kind of
ignited a kind of interesting wine it's
an amazing seller i'd love to have a
seller like that
it's uh and yeah i mean every scene i've
got a glass of something
um so it's yeah it's something i'm very
used to i had to learn how to open a
i didn't even know how to do the cork
thing just something that is
essential for julian um but yeah there's
i mean that's dude he is this person
who's just kind of
he loves getting absolutely wasted he's
a very hedonistic
person he it's a kind of coping
mechanism i think for
kind of all the other craziness that's
going on
completely up for both of you what is it
like returning
on like that first day of season two and
you're stepping back into these
characters
prior to the filming did you guys
re-watch the first season
or was it sort of just like you know you
played these characters for so long i'm
just curious what you did
to get ready for that first day
um i mean for me i think when we did
season one we were out there for such a
such a long time
and we all got pretty well acquainted
with our
characters i'd say i think for me it was
just uh yeah it does definitely take a
minute to
acclimate and to sort of find your
footing back with the character again
there's always that one moment like
in your first shot of the of the season
where you're like oh can i still act can
i still do this do i
do i still understand how this [ __ ]
works so stuff works
so um yeah there's always that and
especially for season two we kind of had
two restarts because we shot six
episodes and then the pandemic happened
and then we had to all go
back home and then go straight back into
it when we came back so
that was definitely challenging but yeah
i think just focusing and
stepping back into the into the world
so what now says he's right it does take
a while to to tune and i think
this the show like this has got such a
specific tone as well
you really want to kind of find the
pitch but as i say like in the how it
kind of stays in the house once you're
kind of back in those rooms it's kind of
it's quite easy to to slip back into it
but um
yeah and also the the accent is is
always something
that you have to kind of keep an eye on
and
that's also another element to
to uh to keep mining but it's yeah it's
it's it's fun it's
it's uh it's a very unique show to be
part of a thing and
this season felt kind of very different
i'm curious obviously this is one of
these series where you can't even say
what's coming up in future episodes
because then you ruin future episodes
but
for fans what can you tease about season
two
i'm probably a bad person to answer this
question because i tend to spoil the
show quite a lot but i'll do i'll do my
best
i would say we can tease there's going
to be more drama
um there's going to be it's kind of
centered around
more of like a missing missing child
kind of element
that can be a lot more supernatural
there's going to be a bit more romance
um and uh more action
yeah there's just it's just kind of
ramped up the volume
quite high on this season so yeah we're
excited
yeah for sure all those things
for sure
okay i'll move on to the next question i
want to uh say congratulations on
getting a third season
uh before the before the second season
even premieres
um knight has talked about i believe
that that um
that the series is he wants to do
something that's 40 episodes
how much do you want to know because
obvi he's told me that he knows how this
thing ultimately ends
how much do you guys want to know
exactly everything about
what's going to happen in the future and
how much as an actor do you want to take
it
script by script yeah i think it's a
kind of double-edged sword i
kind of love not knowing i like going
into it blind
much like the character is and i think
that's one of the thrills of this being
part of the show is you don't really
know you can't it's very hard to predict
kind of what's exactly gonna is is
around the corner
me and now have a bet at the moment nell
thinks she's gonna fly at some point
i'm just saying i think i'm gonna fly it
could happen
you never know you never know so it's
yeah it makes it very exciting i think
to to kind of be in the dark and i think
that's
what knight likes is to to keep it all
kind of mysterious
which is is fun
cool i gotta stop there i'm just gonna
say congrats i can't wait to watch the
rest of season two
so happy for you guys you got a third
season uh good luck
thank you so much cheers thank you very
much